[Music]
on this Sunday night Montreal's police
chief uninvited the anti-racism protests
go on but why wasn't the city's top cop
allowed to comment an independent
investigation is launched after a First
Nations chief claims police brutality
plus a high-profile Republican is
throwing his support behind Democrat Joe
Biden and the ten-year-old who's showing
the world Canada's Got Talent
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us
anti racism rallies are once again
taking place in Canada's second largest
city
Montreal's top cop was supposed to
attend but the chief was uninvited a
group of young black activists asked
that he not come because it's lost
confidence in the police force but this
is a time when others are asking to
repair the relationship between
marginalized communities and police
departments Phil carpenter has our top
story tonight protesters in downtown
Montreal Sunday see the memories are
hard to forget
stories like that are common at this
rally against police brutality and
racism one of several across the country
this weekend Sunday's event was
organized in the wake of the gorge
flight killing in the US but it's meant
to highlight racism and excessive use of
force by police in this country it's not
a it's not a black problem it's an issue
that affects all of us thousands
gathered to hear community leaders and
others express rage and to child
politicians and police for what they see
as inaction on racism like this we make
them uncomfortable and they see what's
going on one person notably absent was
Montreal police chief Sylvain cayhall he
was asked to stay away after organizers
said having him there was a bad idea the
community wasn't ready for it yet they
were ready because the fact that it does
there's a bit of an animosity animosity
that comes from years of difficult
relationships between racialized groups
and the police every a recent study
commissioned by the city found that
black indigenous and Arab people in
Montreal are far more likely to be
stopped by police then there are police
shootings in 2016 violence erupted in
the borough of Montreal north following
a protest against the shooting death of
Jean Pierre Boni and that of Freddie
Villanueva eight years before that at
Sunday's rally organizers say they hope
political and police leadership start
listening to racialized communities they
want this March to be the last aside
from just coming together I'm marching
it's time that we create we create
change we force change collectively Phil
carpenter Global News Montreal the
Assembly of First Nations is calling on
governments and police forces across the
country to review their practices in the
wake of a recent death 26 year old
Chantel Moore was shot and killed
Thursday after police were called to her
home for a wellness check as Ross Lord
explains her death is raising more
questions about the relationship between
indigenous Canadians and police
indigenous leaders from across Canada
are demanding answers about Chantal
mores death the Edmundston Police
Department says an officer called in to
conduct a wellness check ended up
shooting more and killing her Edmonston
police say Moore was holding a knife
confronted the officer and made threats
an explanation her family rejects
Chantal was not well and she was not a
Christmas she was not maintained she was
very friendly and outgoing Maliseet
First Nations in New Brunswick are
calling for an independent probe of the
New Brunswick justice system for what
they call systemic discrimination the
Assembly of First Nations is calling for
an impartial third party investigation
into why lethal force was used and
whether race was a factor national chief
Perry bellegarde asks how does a call
for help turn into a call for the
coroner this should never happen
bellegarde adds all governments should
consider whether an armed response
without proper social supports and
training is ever the correct response to
a wellness check at a time when police
tactics are under close scrutiny Moore's
death raises more questions about the
relationship between police and people
of color I've had some clients who the
police they've called the police because
they themselves are feeling unsafe but
they were met with suspicion or
condescension or they report that they
were met with aggression a team of
investigators from Quebec has been
appointed to examine Moore's death
there's an online petition calling for
the officer to be charged with murder a
separate fundraising campaign for family
travel and funeral costs has raised well
over 100 thousand dollars organizers say
in
remaining proceeds will go to Moores
mother at her five-year-old daughter
Gracie
Ross Lord global news an independent
investigation has been launched into how
RCMP handled the case involving a First
Nations leader chief Allen Adham claims
he was brutally beaten during an arrest
over an expired license plate
our David akin looks at whether these
civilian review agencies can even affect
change it was this photo a bruised and
bloodied chief Allen Adham that factored
into the decision to have Alberta's
civilian police review agency
investigate how RCMP handled Adams March
tenth arrest after RCMP found an expired
license plate sticker on his truck but
this is one of the clearest cases of
unnecessary police brutality the review
was welcomed as an important first step
but in some parts of the country
Saskatchewan for example there is no
civilian agency that can review
complaints about police brutality and
racism the federal RCMP civilian review
and Complaints Commission meanwhile is
backlogged with cases say academic
researchers and parliamentarians though
the Commission itself disputes that
nonetheless it does not have the power
to issue orders or compel change it can
only provide recommendations but Ottawa
for years has had no shortage of calls
for change critics say it now needs to
act that's policy changes to do
something about it it's not enough to
just stay the pretty words sing for
example says police and security
agencies should be prohibited from using
racial profiling as a policing tool and
the criminal justice system should be
revamped to try to reduce the over
representation of non minorities in jail
disproportionately impacted those who
are racialized indigenous people black
people so changing those mandatory
minimums to give discretion back to
judges academics and MPs also say Ottawa
should collect more race-based data
because without measuring
problem the problem remains invisible to
policymakers we need to measure that and
everything access to business loans
access to social services all those
things would be very important and will
be a gift that will keep on giving to
improve the place of reducing anti black
racism in this country singing the NDP
will use their time in parliamentary
proceedings next week to push the
government for specific action to
identify and fight racism in Canada
Robin David akin in Ottawa thanks David
we have developing news in Minneapolis
tonight some members of that city's
council plan to vote to disband the
police force this is the center of the
crisis that has gripped America since
George Floyd was killed while in police
custody today tens of thousands of
protesters gathered once again in cities
and towns across the u.s. calling for an
end to police brutality backed fists say
the black community is suffering on many
levels including systemic racism and
higher rates of Cova 19 and unemployment
here's Jennifer Johnson the protest
server George Floyd's death go on many
demonstrators are calling on police
departments to be defunded not reformed
and for money to instead be poured into
rebuilding black communities Minneapolis
protesters screaming at their mayor for
not agreeing to abolish the city's
police force you're asking whether I'm
for massive structural reform to revise
the structure of structurally racist
system the answer's yes but during a
rally in Minneapolis some members of the
City Council said they intend to disband
their police force and they believe they
have the majority of votes to do it on
Monday two US senators will release a
new bill that includes a ban on certain
police practices which millions are
demanding this is a system that's really
bait that we all have to take
responsibility for and get practices
that just give greater transparency and
greater accountability for those working
police in many black Americans are
frustrated at what they see is more
police brutality higher unemployment
rates than whites and kovat 19 killing a
higher percentage of their population
experts say these demonstrations will
further endanger black protesters based
on new data out of Germany there was
about a two-and-a-half times increase in
the rate of transmission as a result of
bringing people together in large
gatherings so we have some scientific
basis to understand that these these
kinds of settings do create risk despite
the risks the protests don't stop and
now more criticism over US President
Donald Trump's suggestion that military
soldiers should have been deployed to
stop the unrest our military isn't
trained to do this our military is
trained for the battlefield and this
isn't a battlefield in that sense but
American politics has become a
battlefield along with rice for us
generals have now publicly criticized
the president's heavy-handed comments
following Floyd's death Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
former Secretary of State Colin Powell a
Republican is adding his name to the
growing list of high-profile political
types critical of Donald Trump the one
word I have to use with respect to his
but he's been doing for the last of
years it's a word I would never have
used before I never would have used with
any of the four presidents I've worked
for he lies he lies about things and he
gets away with it because people were
not holding accountable Powell says he
didn't speak out before because he felt
he had demonstrated his displeasure with
Trump when he voted against him Powell
says he plans to vote for Democrat doe
Biden for president in November
President Trump was quick to respond in
a tweet he called Powell a real stiff
and Biden another stiff there were more
anti-racism protests all over the UK
today thousands gathered outside the US
Embassy in London to condemn police
brutality and in Bristol demonstrators
toppled a statue of a prominent slave
trader and dumped it into the harbor the
city was the center Britain's prosperous
slave trade in the 17th century still to
come the pandemic has paralyzed travel
plans why climate activists are pleased
[Applause]
and the ten yield Ontario girl making
music and stunning the judges
the United Nations agency that oversees
air travel the International Civil
Aviation Organization estimates Global
Travel will see a drop of 1.2 billion
travelers in 2020 and the result is the
largest ever annual drop in co2
emissions this year as Reverend Shannon
reports even climate activists are
caught off-guard by the impact when
doable news first met Anna Hughes last
year she had a grand idea on climate
action to get 100,000 people to promise
not to fly in 2020
it's an achievable aim for just a year
but it's also it's really hard cut to
2020 and instead of 100,000 millions of
us are grounded I mean lots of people
say wow flight free 2020 is going really
well but yeah it's totally mad I mean
you look up at the sky and usually
that'd be maybe five or six plays in the
sky that you'd be able to count and
there's none and it's quite
disconcerting actually because this the
campaign we were running was within the
context of normal and this isn't normal
this is not the version of success
campaigners like Anna Hughes wanted to
see this is an action that people have
been forced to take so obviously the
whole purpose of our campaign is that we
want people to choose not to fly if you
choose you feel empowered you have other
options that's really important
worldwide about 25,000 people promised
to stay on the ground including some
people in Canada but one traveler who
signed up to the pledge had an epic land
and sea voyage cut short by the pandemic
British travel blogger Stephanie Parker
only got as far as Morocco on her trip
that was months in the making not flying
sort of reinjected this sense of
adventure and excitement which is what I
love love from travel so the Morocco
section was actually the beginning of an
eight months overland adventure I had
planned the irony was Parker had to
quickly fly home as countries close to
their borders obviously at that time I
felt really really sad to have broken on
the pledge I made
but it also reminded me of like you know
sometimes we make these commitments to
ourselves but there's greater forces at
work if we choose this and we can choose
this so once lockdown is lifted we can
choose to holiday closer to home we can
choose to just take those the the
positive parts of this if there are any
and you know apply them to our normal
lives whenever they return flight free
plans to have a new set of goals for a
greener travel in 2021 Redmond Shannon
Global News London
still ahead how do you safely protest in
a pandemic more of your Kovan 19
questions answered you are watching
global national
[Music]
in the fallout from George Floyd's death
tens of thousands around the world
continue to rally against racism it's a
cause many are risking their health and
safety for especially in a pandemic
today the number of deaths caused by
Cova 19 surpassed 400,000 worldwide now
there are concerns those large crowds
gathering in close contact could spread
the deadly coronavirus are Jeff sample
takes those concerns straight to the
experts thousands have taken to the
streets across the country marching
against racism and police brutality and
sparking questions from some viewers
about protesting in a pandemic hi Jeff
my name is Judy Bissell and I'm here in
Calgary Alberta my question is why are
people allowed to publicly gather and
protest disobeying public health
restrictions possibly creating an
increase in community transmission of
the covin 19 virus missile worries for
her mother who lives with dementia in a
long-term care home no visitors allowed
during the pandemic so and certainly
there are some contradictions here
protest is very important especially in
the company that we live in but yes you
know when you're outside protesting
there is a risk of transmission
especially when you're in a large group
health experts urged protesters to wear
masks keep their distance and avoid
shouting people shouting hollering
singing chanting those are the kinds of
activities that from an infected person
would actually expand quite a bit public
health officials recommend wearing a
mask and to avoid touching your face
easier said than done
so we have this glow germ powder which
is used in contamination studies to show
how germs can spread I've put some on my
hands already assuming I touched a
contaminated surface and now I'm gonna
put on my mask like I would before I
start the day and go out now fast
forward and let's assume I'm about to
eat my lung
so now I need to take my mask off and
there you go and just like that you can
see in the backlight where I've touched
and potentially contaminated my face dr.
Suman chakravarthi shows how it's done
and you can wash your hands you wanna
touch the loops close your eyes he
recommends changing or washing your mask
after each outing my name is Janice I'm
from maple ridge and I'm interested in
knowing how well the recovered folks are
doing what percentage were left with
medical issues
we don't have long-term data on
persistent symptoms after recovery but
in the short-term the hardest-hit
patients have suffered scarring of the
lungs and damage to their heart and
nervous system around ten percent of
Canada's cases have been hospitalized
two percent requiring intensive care
unit can take a long long time to
recover a reminder that even some who
survived may never be the same
Jeff sample global news Toronto you may
want to check the hand sanitizer you're
using six types are being recalled by
Health Canada the products are made with
industrial grade ethanol health Canada
says their use could lead to dry skin
irritation or cracking consumers are
advised to stop using the products
immediately you can find the list on our
website global news dot CA / global
national
up next look who's got talent a Canadian
girl stuns America with a golden voice
[Music]
like too many young kids Roberta
Battaglia was being bullied by some of
her peers but she may not be getting
taunted any longer that's because the 10
year old has a gift that has stunned
some of the biggest names in the
entertainment world you go out there and
show them what you got okay
with the spotlight shining down the
nerves and excitement are rising eyes
Sam is something boy this young Canadian
showed America and the world she's got
talent
[Applause]
I was just so excited for my dream to
finally come true with a singing voice
far beyond her years
Roberta Battaglia stunned the celebrity
judges and more than eight million
people watched at home but the
ten-year-old from Brampton Ontario is
already a seasoned pro
[Music]
she's been singing since the age of
three accompanied by her dad my dad was
he and he still is a musician and you
know I used to pick up from his
footsteps and now she's hoping to follow
in the footsteps of superstars like Katy
Perry
[Music]
jazz legend Etta James and one star she
truly looks up to pink because she's
just an amazing singer her range is
unbelievable but having a talent at a
young age isn't always easy but
sometimes I do get bullied and you know
what let's see who is going to bully you
after this
[Music]
with the push of that golden buzzer
Battaglia jumps into the finals and now
the bullies are likely singing a much
different tune cause you have to do was
stay strong and you never gotta let
yourself down the preteen is already
working on an album while continuing her
schooling online and she's hoping she'll
be able to return to the AGT stage at
the Dolby Theatre in Los Angeles where
she hopes to wow the judges again and
where she could potentially become the
youngest winner in the talent shows
history let's hope that this goes away
so he could do it in Hollywood it's a
golden moment for a bright and rising
star and fingers crossed that she wins
that is global national for this Sunday
I'm Robin Gill tonight your Canada is
the clear blue sky over Brookfield
Newfoundland and Labrador we'd love to
see your corner of this country so send
your photos to viewers at global
national calm thank you for watching
good night
[Music]